[Aplausos]
se trata de un nivel inigualable de
confianza bilateral el Primer Ministro
indio no tiene suficientes palabras para
elogiar la relación entre Francia y su
país Francia e India son las dos
principales potencias que bordean el
océano Índico por lo tanto nuestra
asociación es vital para la paz y
estabilidad de la región de lindo
Pacífico que queremos que sea libre
abierta e inclusiva segura y estable el
presidente francés ha decidido apostar a
lo grande por este socio especial
narendra modi es el invitado de honor
para la celebraciones del 14 de Julio
las tropas indias desfilarán por los
campos elíseos con motivo del Día
Nacional y los mandatarios celebrarán
una cena oficial con más de 200
invitados en el corazón del Museo de luz
pero esta visita también genera
descontento minoría religiosas agredidas
oposición cada vez más amordazada y
Libertad de prensa abucheada son
alegatos de opositores indios y algunas
ong instaladas en París e indignadas al
ver arentra mod y tratado con tanta
consideración por creer que esos años
está dando un giro autoritaria es
posible que no tengamos que desplegar la
alfombra roja para el Primer Ministro
modi pero tampoco guardar silencio sobre
cuestiones de Derechos Humanos una
asociación estratégica debe basarse en
valores compartidos y la defensa de los
Derechos Humanos debe ser parte de estos
valores comunes el gobierno francés basa
Esta visita sobre todo en lo económico
con la esperanza de firmar nuevos
acuerdos de hecho el Primer Ministro
indio podría aprovechar su Estancia para
anunciar la compra de al menos 26
aviones rafle París también espera
vender varios submarinos según informan
medios locales